I love my drive through coffee in the morning
as much as the next gal, but the cup it comes
in?
Not so much.
It could stay in landfill FOREVER.
But hey maybe the early worm gets the disposable
foam.
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
Plastic can be great.
It’s durable, flexible, and used in everything
from medical equipment to floss, to the cup
my coffee comes in.
Buuuut, unfortunately, most plastics either
don’t or take a very long time to break
down.
Most plastics are made from processes like
heating up petroleum, this rearranges the
molecules so it becomes polypropylene, forged
together by strong carbon-carbon bonds.
These strong bonds are hard to break apart,
and because it takes a lot of energy to make
molecules like polypropylene, nature doesn’t
break them down by itself.
Kenneth Peters, an organic geochemist at Stanford
University, told LiveScience that "Nature
doesn't make things like that, so organisms
have never seen that before."
But we seem addicted to the stuff.
It makes things cheap and disposable and makes
getting your morning cup of joe a little easier.
Speaking of those cups of coffee, they are
one of the worst offenders!
While great at holding hot coffee, it’s
terrible at breaking down.
It could sit there in a landfill for thousands
of years.
But there is some good news two studies published
in the journal Environmental Science and Technology
suggest the creepy mealworm is to the rescue!
The researchers found that the mealworm has
microbes in their guts that can break down
the foam.
How?
Well by feeding them nothing but the nasty
stuff.
But they're not big eaters, 100 worms ate
about 34 and 39 milligrams a day!
Okay that’s really not that much.
But still, it’s better than nothing.
After digesting the stuff the worms released
half as carbon dioxide and pooped out the
other half as little pellets.
Early results say that the pellets might safe
enough to use as soil!
WHAT WAY COOL.
Still preliminary though.
Earlier studies also published in the journal
Environmental Science & Technology found other
microbes that could help.
These microbes live in the guts of another
worm, the waxworm which is a moth larva.
These microbes chow down on polyethylene,
the most common plastic; it's often used in
packaging.
But these worms aren’t alone in their dining
habits, there’s a fungus in the rainforests
in Ecuador that can eat only plastic.
Described in the journal Applied and Environmental
Microbiology, the fungus Pestalotiopsis microspora
could survive on polyurethane alone.
And the researchers say there could be loads
of other fungus species that could be great
bioremediation candidates, but we just haven’t
found them yet.
The only problem though is we’re losing
precious rainforest at five thousand kilometers
a year.
So we might not have enough time to find the
fungus we need.
But maybe mother nature doesn’t have all
the answers.
To take down something man-made, maybe we
have to give mother nature a hand.
For the past ten years, MIT hosts a competition
that encourages students to design a living
cell.
Yeah, you heard that right, design.
Every year students from all over their world
try their hand at genetic engineering in The
International Genetically Engineered Machine
(iGEM) Competition.
While not all students try to make bacteria
that eats plastic, in 2013 a group of students
at UC Davis tried creating a bacteria that
would eat a type of plastic called PET.
But genetic engineering can be controversial.
What happens if you release it into the wild?
We don’t know if or how the new organism
might mutate, or how if it could become an
invasive species.
And as for more “natural” bacteria it’s
not a silver bullet solution.
We should be very cautious before we go spraying
bacteria and fungus over everything plastic.
We have no idea how these kinds of organisms
could handle a new environment.
There’s a real fear they could TAKE OVER.
Like the fungus from the rainforest?
Yeah it’s known to cause “rot and disease
in a wide variety of plant species”, not
good if it gets loose across the planet.
So it’s clear more research is needed, but
researchers are on the right track.
Until a perfect solution is found, maybe we
should keep plastic out of landfills and out
of the environment with the old standby of
reduce, reuse and recycle.
But the other question is, does it really
help?
We are told every day that we should be recycling,
but why?
What happens to plastic bottles when they’re
not recycled?
Amy’s got the answers in this video right
here.
So what do you think about plastic eating
animals?
Let me down in the comments below